Sistir ist mein Name, ich bin der Assistenz der Aufwärtssituation und für den Genen das Aufnahmegeschichte mit Ihren Führern.
Sind Sie damit ein Verstand?
Natürlich, aber ich habe Ihren Namen nicht verstanden. Können Sie Ihren Namen einmal buchstabieren?
Ja, mein Name ist Sistir, C-I-S-T-I-R.
Sistir, okay, verstehe.
Ja, Sistir, genau.
Bevor Sie mir über Ihre Becheverde erzählen, würde ich am Anfang ein paar Allgemeine fragen, wie heißt sie?
Sieb-Urzula König.
König ist wie König?
Ja, richtig.
Okay, wann sind Sie genau, wie war das König?
Ich bin am 25.04.1967 geboren.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ja, das sind 55 Jahre alt.
Können Sie mir bitte verraten, wie groß Sie sind und wie viel Sie wissen?
Ja, ich bin 1,70 m groß und wiege ungefähr 61 kg.
So, Frau König, was für Sie uns, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Also ich habe seit mehreren Wochen immer wieder mal so krampfartige Schmerzen, so genau da oben im Bauchbereich.
Und manchmal ist das ziemlich stark, dass ich die Wände hoch klettern könnte.
Und ich habe gemerkt, ich habe auch in letzter Zeit ein Gewicht verloren.
Wie viel Gewicht haben Sie verloren?
Ja, ungefähr so 4 kg.
Über welche Zeitraum?
Ja, das dürften so 2 Monate sein.
Seit 2 Monaten, Sie haben 4 kg abgenommen.
Können Sie mir bitte sagen, wo Sie genau in der Zwischenraum sind?
Genau da, in dem Zwischenraum, also genau unter den Rippen, genau in der Mitte.
Unter dem Rippen, genau in der Mitte.
Ja.
Inter-Iren-Bloos-Bein.
Ja, wenn man das so bezeichnet, ja.
Okay.
Haben Ihre Schmerzen langsam oder plötzlich begonnen?
Haben mich gar nicht mal dran erinnern.
Ich weiß nur, dass Sie kommen und gehen.
Wie Sie genau angefangen haben, weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Ich würde gerne mal fragen, sind die Ihre Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Die gehen auch mal weg, die sind nicht immer da.
Also wenn Sie kommen, sind die sehr stark, aber die gehen auch mal weg zwischen euch.
Können Sie mir bitte Ihre Schmerzen einschätzen auf einer Schmaskulapone 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leid und 10 sehr stark schmerzend, wenn Sie Krampfe haben und wenn Sie keine Krampfe haben.
Also ich würde in dem Falle sagen, das ist so um die Acht, das ist schon sehr stark.
Wenn Sie keine Krampfe haben, spüren Sie nichts?
Nee, dann sind Sie mal weg, dann habe ich keine Wischwerden, aber wenn Sie kommen,
ist es extrem Schmerzen.
Haben Sie gerade Schmerzen momentan?
Jetzt momentan nicht, nein.
Meistens habe ich das, wenn ich etwas gegessen habe, habe ich gemerkt.
Nach dem Essen.
Nach dem Essen oder während dem Essen fängt es so an und danach ist es extrem stark.
Ist das abhängig davon, was Sie essen?
Teilweise wenn ich so fettige Sachen oder gebratene Sachen esse, zum Beispiel im Braten oder in Hühnchen,
dann tut es noch mehr weh, aber so leichte Kosten merke ich, das ist nicht so schmerzend.
Wann treten Ihre Schmerzen auf, eher in der Nacht oder tagsüber?
Also eher tagsüber, nicht in der Nacht.
Ist es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Ihre Schmerzen eine Auslöser habt?
Um Schmerzen eine Auslöser haben, also es kann ja mehrere Sachen sein.
Nee, also Ihr, während Deinen bestimmten Auslöser habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie etwas ausprobiert um Ihre Schmerzen zu wenden?
Nee, ich war mal in der Apotheke, die haben mir mal so eine Milchigeflüssigkeit,
nennt sich glaube ich Riopan oder so, das hatten Sie mal gegeben.
Und wenn die Schmerzen mal extrem stark sind, dann trinke ich mal so ein Beutel, dann lassen die Schmerzen nach.
Also das hat Ihnen geholfen?
Ja, das hält nur nicht lange, die gehen nicht weg, die kommen wieder irgendwann.
Mhm, mhm.
Angesichts, niedergebracht können wir sagen, okay.
Mhm.
Können Sie mir bitte den Namen der Medikamenta wieder sagen?
Ja, da steht Riopan drauf, also R-I-O-P-A-N, Riopan.
Riopan, okay, danke.
Mhm.
Wenn Sie mal wieder ein bisschen verheiratet haben, dann ist das etwas ausprobiert.
Nee, eigentlich nicht, nee, das ist immer da oben in dem Bereich Ausstrahlen,
habe ich jetzt nicht bemerkt, vielleicht ein bisschen so im Rücken in dem Bereich,
aber so richtig ausstrahlen tun Sie nicht mal.
Okay.
Hat Sie ein Furier-Rennich-Ebächer?
Nee, was ich hatte ist, dass ich hin und wieder mal so einen Ausstoßen hatte
und Nacht hin und wieder mal so einen Sodbrennen im Mund verspürt habe.
Ich konnte Akustik schuldigung nicht verstanden, Sie haben Ausstoßen?
Ja, ich habe in der Vergangenheit hin und wieder mal Ausstoßen gehabt
und gelegentlich habe ich auch mal so Sodbrennen verspürt.
Okay, danke.
Seit wann können Sie sagen, seit jemals oder seit Monatens?
Das dürften einige Jahre her sein, also bestimmt 4-5 Jahre, würde ich schon sagen.
Okay.
Können Sie mir bitte ein bisschen mehr beschreiben?
Sie haben sich auch immer aufgemacht?
Also, das sind mehr so stechende bis kampfende Schmerzen.
Mhm, so fragt König.
Ich habe noch einige Fragen über Ihre Allgemeinsruchstatt.
Haben Sie Fibar?
Fibar habe ich nicht.
Sie haben mir gesagt, dass Sie in letztes zwei Monaten 4 kg abgenommen haben.
Wie ist Ihr Habitit?
Also, der Habitit hat so ein bisschen nachgelassen.
Also, ich habe eigentlich einen ganz guten Habitit gehabt,
aber so in den letzten zwei Monaten habe ich gemerkt,
er hat so ein bisschen nachgelassen.
Also, Sie essen weniger vegane Rebechewerden?
Ja, richtig.
Haben Sie Erbrechen?
Erbrochen habe ich nicht.
Hat die Farbe ihre Sturz oder ihre Sturz geändert?
Ja, vor zwei Wochen hatte ich den Eindruck,
er ist ein bisschen dunkel geworden, so schwarz,
aber dann war er ganz schnell wieder in Ordnung.
Vor zwei Wochen ist es einmal schwarz geworden,
oder war es mehr malig?
Einmal, wie gesagt, das ist nicht jetzt dauernd gewesen.
Ich habe das nur einmal schon gemacht,
okay.
Haben Sie auch Abgeschlägenheit?
Fühlen Sie sich müde?
Hallo?
Also, so ein bisschen habe ich den Eindruck schon,
dass die Leistung so ein bisschen nachgelassen hat.
Aber jetzt nicht so dramatisch,
dass ich sagen würde, ich kann gar nichts mehr machen.
Ich merke nur, ich bin nicht mehr so gut,
ich habe nicht mehr so gut,
ich habe nicht mehr so gut, ich kann gar nichts mehr machen.
Ich merke nur, ich bin nicht mehr so ganz fit.
Ja, Sie haben auch Schmerzen,
das kann auch beeinflussen.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Leider Sie unter Insomoda.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten beim Einschlafen,
durchschlafen?
Sagen wir mal, haben Sie Schlafstörungen, sagen wir dazu.
Aber nee, Schlafstörungen habe ich nicht.
Das ist alles so weit in Ordnung.
Mussten Sie wegen Ihres Schmerzen in der Nacht aufwachen?
Also in der Nacht sind die Schmerzen selten.
Aufwachen muss ich davon nicht, das ist mehr tagsüber.
Wie gesagt, abhängig davon, wenn ich etwas esse.
Aber nachts habe ich die Schmerzen nicht.
Ist es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass die Farbe Ihres Urins verandert hat?
Was habe das Urins?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Nicht?
Ist es Ihnen aufgefallen, dass auch Konsistenz Ihres Sturz
oder Geruch Ihres Sturz geandert hat?
Nein, ich bin nicht aufgefallen.
Okay.
Frau König, lassen Sie uns über Ihre Vorgeschichte beschreiben.
Leider Sie an Konischenerkrankungen?
Zum Beispiel?
Zum Beispiel.
Wie Blutzucker oder Bluthochdruck?
Nein, weder noch nicht.
Ich bin eigentlich kerngesund gewesen.
Okay, sehr gut.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Wenn die Schmerzen im Oberpauch sehr, sehr stark sind,
dann nehme ich mal so eine Aspirin ein.
Aber sonst nehme ich keine Medikamente ein.
Haben Sie Ihnen letztens auch Aspirin eingenommen?
Ja, aber nicht jetzt sehr viel.
Vielleicht nur ein, zwei Mal in der Woche.
Wie viel Milligramm Aspirin nehmen Sie ein?
Man sich gar nicht nehmen, wenn man nur eine Tablette ein.
Ich glaube, da sind 500 oder so drauf.
500?
Nein, 500 Milligramm stehen da drauf, glaube ich.
Kann es sein, dass Sie dieses Schwarzstuhl nach dem Aspirin Einnahme gehabt haben?
Nein, das hatte vorher schon begonnen.
Ich hatte nun wieder mal Schmerzen.
Und dann habe ich erst Aspirin genommen.
Also die Schmerzen waren definitiv vorher da.
Okay.
Frau König, Sie sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Nein, ich hatte bisher keine Operation.
Keine Operation, gut.
Sind Sie schon einmal stationär behandelt worden?
Kann ich mich jetzt nicht mehr genau erinnern, aber ich glaube, wegen einer schweren Lungenentzündung war ich mal als Jugendliche im Krankenhaus, aber sonst nicht.
Wie alt waren Sie damals?
Wie sind Sie?
Ich glaube, 16 oder 17 damals, aber sonst nicht mehr.
Sie wurden aber komplikationslos entlassen?
Ja, da habe ich dann so ungefähr 10 Tage im Krankenhaus gelegen und die Ärzte haben dann gesagt, das ist alles wieder okay.
Und dann ist dann auch weggegangen.
Das war gut.
Okay, sehr gut.
Frau König, sind Sie bei Ihnen allergienbekannt?
Wir gehen sind mir nicht bekannt, nein.
Abgesehen von fertiger Essen, haben Sie noch andere Unfertiglichkeiten gegen Nahrungsmitteln?
Mir nicht bekannt, nein.
Okay, sind Sie vorständig geimpft?
Na ja, ich bin dreimal geimpft.
Sie sind dreimal geimpft, keine Unfertiglichkeiten.
Wir sind gleichfertig, ich benutze nur ein paar Informationen über Ihre Gewohnheiten.
Frau König, rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich habe nie geraucht.
Sie sind nicht raucherin.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ganz selten.
Wie oft können Sie sagen?
Einmal alle paar Monate, wenn wir mal eingeladen sind oder so, vielleicht ein Glas Wein, aber mehr nicht.
Ein Glas Wein, okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routine Frage, deswegen muss ich das einstellen.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit den Drogen?
Drogen? Nein, mit Drogen habe ich nicht damit.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Wir sind verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, wir sind kerngesund, den fehlt nichts, Gott sei Dank.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Die Jüngste ist 15 und die Ältere ist 18 Jahre alt.
18 Jahre alt, okay.
Frau König, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Managerin in der Bank.
Gibt es irgendwas, auch im arbeitsplatz, das Sie belastet?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Wenn Sie Stress meinen?
Ja, natürlich, als Managerin müssen Sie viele Leute beaufsichtigen, koordinieren.
Da fehlt dann schon sehr viel Arbeit und das ist schon stressig, muss man sagen.
Findest du Sie, dass Sie seit mehrstens mehr stressig sind?
Nein, der Stress ist immer da. Stressfrei bin ich nicht, aber ist auch nicht mehr geworden.
Okay.
Sind Sie gesund?
Nein, ich habe nichts gesagt.
Okay.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige Krankheiten, von denen ich wissen sollte, Frau König?
Wie meinen Sie das?
Wie chronische Krankheiten, Zuckerbluthochdrück oder Krebs?
Nein, es gab es in der Familie nicht.
Leben und ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, meine Eltern leben noch beide, die sind so weit in Ordnung.
Sehr gut. Leidens Sie an chronischen Krankungen?
Ja, meine Mutter hat so ein Drittes an den Hüftgelenken.
Mein Vater hat so ein bisschen Herzschwäche, das ist aber alles.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder, der ist jünger als ich.
Dem geht es aber gut.
Ja, Frau König, ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Haben Sie noch Fragen an mich oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, muss ich hier bleiben oder darf ich nach Hause?
Wie läuft das ab?
Ich werde Sie zuerst körperlich unterzogen.
Dann werde ich bei Ihnen ein paar Unterzogen d'übchen.
Sie können mindestens zwei, drei Stunden dauern.
Sobald alle Befunde vorlegen, können wir mit Ihnen ausführlich
ein bisschen überlegen, ob Sie hier bleiben müssen oder nach Hause gehen können.
Okay, gut, ich verstehe.
Okay, dann können wir anfangen.
Ja, natürlich.
Okay, dann das war es.
Ja, dann können wir anfangen.
Wenn es keine weiteren Fragen von den Kollegen gibt?
Ja, gibt es Fragen?
Keine Fragen zu haben, dann können wir auch übergehen.
Okay, guten Tag Herr Oberass.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen und würde gerne diese Patientin vorstellen.
Hatten Sie eine kurze Zeit für mich?
Ja, eine kurze Zeit für mich.
Okay, danke.
Frau Ursula König ist eine 54-jährige Patientin,
die sich bei uns wegen seit mehreren Wochen bestehenden,
krampfartige Oberbau schmerzsinn folgen sich der Tat.
Die Patientin hat erheblich schmerzsinn,
postprandial und besonders nach den Fektiken und Gebratinnen
und Taxuber auftreten.
Und die Auslöser für die Beschwerden wurde verneint.
Die Patientin hat angegeben, dass sie von der Apotheke
eine Reopaneinnahme etwas verbessert hat.
Sagen wir mal, formulieren wir das mal ein bisschen anders.
Sagen Sie doch, von der Apotheker hat sie sich Reopane besorgt,
die sie in der Apotheke besorgt hat.
Sie hat sich von der Apotheke besorgt,
Sie hat von der Apotheker Reopane besorgt,
die sie in der Apotheke besorgt hat.
Die Patientin hat in der Apotheke besorgt,
die sie in der Apotheker besorgt hat.
Die Patientin hat keine Erbruch, kein Erbruch.
Die Patientin hat keine Erbruch.
Die Frage nach Schlafstörungen wurde verneint.
Die Patientin hat bemerkt, dass sie für zwei Wochen eine Melene hat.
Sie hat aber bei der Urin keine Farbeveränderung bemerkt.
Urin Farbeveränderungen hat sie nichts bemerkt.
Sie hat nicht bei dem Stuhl, sondern im Stuhl.
Das Stuhl hat sie nicht bemerkt.
Sie hat eine leichte Leistungsunfähigkeit.
Anhand der Drückschmarsch im Epigastriumbereich und der krampfartige Postbrandierchmarsch,
gehe ich von einer Qualistitis aus.
Sie hat eine Fieber oder Schüttelfrost gehabt oder geschwitzt.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hat einmal Melena gehabt.
Sie hat keine Stuhlaufhellung.
Sie hat eine Stuhlaufhellung.
Sie hat eine stabilisierte Stabilität.
Sie hat eine Stabilität.